das virus und die wirtschaft immer mehr
betriebe befürchten probleme
die bundesregierung berät jetzt über
hilfen corona fälle in den usa auch in
den staaten steigen die zahlen präsident
trump sein land aber gut vorbereitet
podestplatz zum saisonabschluss die
deutschen biathletinnen holen im letzten
staffelrennen noch einmal bronze
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am samstag
mit ausführlichem sport und norbert
lehmann beim schwimmen haben doch von
mir und auch heute dreht sich bei uns
alles zunächst um das corona virus denn
abgesehen von der gesundheitlichen
gefahr hat die epidemie erhebliche
folgen für die wirtschaft und zwar
weltweit das spüren hierzulande
besonders die unternehmen die entweder
selbst in china arbeiten oder sich von
dort beliefern lassen
die zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft nach den
usa leidet nämlich enorm unter der virus
krise
die chinesischen exporte brechen ein
im januar und februar um mehr als 17
prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr und
auch in der deutschen wirtschaft wachsen
die sorgen die spitzen der großen
koalition prüfen jetzt hilfen für
unternehmen vertritt wiedemeier mit den
details auch in deutschland erwartet
jedes zweite unternehmen laut einer
umfrage des industrie- und handelstages
für dieses jahr einen umsatzrückgang
lieferketten sind unterbrochen
zulieferteile etwa aus norditalien
fehlen um die erheblichen
wirtschaftlichen folgen abzufedern
kündigt der arbeitsminister für
betroffene firmen eine ausweitung des
kurzarbeitergeldes an
wir haben rücklagen bei der
bundesagentur für arbeit aus den guten
zeiten der arbeitsmarktentwicklung und
insgesamt 26 milliarden euro das heißt
wir sind für schwierige zeiten gerüstet
wie stellt jetzt die instrumente zur
verfügung
dringend nötig denn die lufthansa zum
beispiel streicht in den nächsten wochen
etwa 50 prozent ihrer flüge ebenfalls
schon jetzt betroffen ist das hotel und
gaststättengewerbe da zahlreiche messen
abgesagt wurden ein notfallkonzept für
die wirtschaft fordern jetzt alle doch
wie dieses aussehen soll
umstritten wirtschaftsminister altmaier
legte einen drei stufen plan vor denkt
über kreditprogramme für angeschlagene
firmen nach die spd bilden so die abbau
vorziehen die csu fordert
steuerstundungen und bürgschaften
wir brauchen schnelle liquiditätshilfen
für unternehmen denen das geld ausgeht
wir brauchen einen einfachen
zugang zum kurzarbeitergeld und wir
brauchen auch wirksame investitionen um
in diesem umfeld auch unternehmen zu
unterstützen
die opposition begrüßt die pläne der
regierung fordert jetzt vor allem rasche
und unbürokratische hilfe der drei
stufen plan von der alb erhält durchaus
sinnvolle komponenten allerdings wichtig
ist dass den unternehmen die in
schwierigkeiten sind schnell geholfen
wird morgen abend wird sich der
koalitionsausschuss unter anderem mit
möglichen hilfen für die wirtschaft
beschäftigen
das robert koch institut spricht heute
von fast 800 infizierten mehr als 200
davon im kreis heinsberg in nordrhein
westfalen
was den alltag für viele bewohner dort
stark einschränkt wie aber bereitet sich
deutschland insgesamt auf höhere
fallzahlen vor thomas münten hat
untersucht was passiert wenn viele der
menschen krank werden die uns täglich
versorgen
gerade im rettungsdienst und beim
brandschutz sind alle feuerwehren
bundesweit vorbereitet wir waren der
woche tag zum beispiel in düsseldorf der
krisenstab der städtischen behörden
direkt bei der feuerwehr
allein 200 rettungskräfte sind täglich
notwendig um alle dienste zu besetzen
bei massiven ausfällen muss reagiert
werden
es gibt rund 1000 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter um den dienstbetrieb bei der
berufsfeuerwehr aufrecht zu erhalten
dazu kommt die freiwillige feuerwehr und
topgesetzt ist also derzeit laufen da
nicht die vorbereitungen richtung
katastrophenschutz für die feuerwehr
düsseldorf sondern man ist noch hierher
der lage wir sind auf jeden fall darauf
vorbereitet auch einzelne
krankheitsfälle hier auffangen zu können
das leitstellen personal wird bereits
abgeschottet sollte sich die lage weiter
zuspitzen stunden auch noch das
technische hilfswerk und die
katastrophenschützer in bereitschaft
ähnlich sieht es auch bei den meisten
verkehrsunternehmen aus in essen und
mülheim fertig ruhe bahnen 1100
fahrerinnen und fahrer sorgen für den
betrieb wenn nur noch 400 arbeiten
können wird reagiert dann würden wir
also das netz zusammen fahren nur noch
die wichtigsten linien fahren und auch
dann nur und dann zu zeiten wo halt
viele fahrgäste noch transportiert
werden müssen vielleicht auch mal sachen
ausfallen lassen vor allem die
u-bahnlinien in und zwischen den städten
sollen bundesweit wenn möglich ohne
unterbrechung fahren
stichwort müll hier gibt es große
unterschiede
viele großstädter haben bereits geplant
andere lassen das thema auf sich
zukommen
die zielsetzung aber ist klar restmüll
soll möglichst lückenlos überall weiter
abgeholt werden
das wäre es uns seine ausbreitung
verunsichert viele menschen wie umgehen
mit dieser angst ein interview mit einem
risikoforscher finden sie online bei uns
auf heute.de zwei wochen lang schulfrei
haben von nun an all die kinder in
bayern wie aus dem urlaub in südtirol
kommen
das hat das bayerische
gesundheitsministerium entschieden grund
südtirol gilt aus deutscher sicht als
risikogebiet weil bei dutzenden
heimkehrern das krone virus nachgewiesen
wurde
ein schwerer schlag für den tourismus
entsprechend ratlos und verärgert ist
man dort annette hilsenbeck einmotten
stadt eröffnung eigentlich beginnt im
designhotel von florian gartner jetzt
die sommersaison
doch es hagelt absagen weil deutsche
behörden vor dem corona virus in
südtirol warnen sein hotel bleibt zu
die mitarbeiter zu hause der hotelier
ist empört
es gebe hier schließlich nur wenige
fällen den ganzen auswirkungen haben für
mich erwecken bei mir den anschein als
ob man nazis thematisiert würde jetzt
mann hat sich in europa an schwarzen
peter gesucht und in südtirol
offensichtlich gefunden
noch läuft die skisaison stehen die
gäste an den lift doch seit deutschland
hier risikogebiet ausgerufen hat
betragen die stornierung bis zu 95
prozent so manche herberge muss
frühzeitig schließen
das hat wirtschaftliche auswirkungen es
wird jetzt wohl eine sehr schlecht dar
überhaupt keine ostersaison geben die
wintersaison läuft früh raus und das ist
allen bewusst dass trifft im besonderen
tourismuswirtschaft hat die ski saison
zu ende und die wandersaison startet gar
nicht erst richtig aus mangel an gästen
aus deutschland wird deutsche gäste die
hier sind unverständlich ich fühle mich
unglaublich sicher und wirklich
unglaublich weil hier ganz wenig
menschen los sind ich bin hamburgerin
und in hamburg würde ich mich derzeit
unsicherer fühlen
doch es geht nicht nur um die
ansteckungsgefahr sondern die
konsequenzen
denn wer aus südtirol nach deutschland
zurückkehrt muss in quarantäne
wir gehen eigentlich die amerikaner mit
dem corona virus um
bislang gibt es offiziell etwa 300
infektionen 17 patienten sind nach
angaben der regierung gestorben
präsident trump sagt verglichen mit
anderen ländern sei das wenig experten
kritisieren allerdings dass viel zu
wenige tests durchgeführt würden
ines trams berichtet desinfektion der
new yorker u-bahn später als in europa
kommt dass corona virus nun auch in den
usa an
immer mehr us bundesstaaten melden
infizierte besonders betroffen ein
altenheim in washington state angehörige
klagen an
tests hätten dort zwölf todesfälle
verhindern können
irgendjemand hat entschieden dass diese
gruppe von menschen es nicht wert oder
ressourcen zu verschwenden die touristen
auf der grand princess vor der
kalifornischen küste bekommen tests per
seilwinde herabgelassen
doch es mehren sich alarmierende
berichte vor allem von personal in
kliniken es fehlt an tests präsident rom
hält die nervosität für übertrieben es
sein die demokraten und die tram
kritische presse wie das corona virus
aufbauschen
jeder der heute oder gestern einen test
wollte bekommt ihn es gibt sie so schöne
tests
wir sind wirklich wachsam wir machen
einen großartigen job die zahlen niedrig
zu halten
james vizepräsident zuständig für das
krisen-management widerspricht bislang
haben wir nicht genügend tests um den
bedarf der auf uns zukommt zu decken
insgesamt wurden in den usa nur knapp
2000 menschen bislang getestet nicht
genug um das virus einzudämmen
man sollte nicht nur testen wenn ein
arzt danach fragt sondern auch um zu
bestimmen wo stehen wir was passiert
unter dem radar
dafür brauchen wir millionen und
abermillionen von test vergleichsweise
wenig betroffene in den usa vielleicht
weil so wenig getestet wurde
die dunkelziffer könnte viel höher
liegen und den präsidenten bald schon
einholen
in china ist ein als quarantäne-station
genutztes hotel eingestürzt und hat rund
70 menschen unter sich begraben
rettungsteams in der küstenstadt donsol
konnten bis zur stunde 38 verschüttete
retten
wie die behörden mitteilten das hotel
hatte 80 zimmer dort waren
kontaktpersonen von corona patienten
untergebracht warum das erst knapp zwei
jahre alte gebäude einstürzte ist noch
unklar
brutale szenen auch heute an der grenze
zwischen der türkei und griechenland
seit präsident erdogan den übergang für
offen erklärt hat versuchen zehntausende
flüchtlinge in die eu zu gelangen
viele aber stecken zwischen den fronten
fest griechische sicherheitskräfte
blocken sie ab gleichzeitig treiben
türkische soldaten sie offenbar in
richtung grenze immerhin etwas
entspannung vor den griechischen inseln
per boot will die türkei die migranten
nicht mehr nach griechenland lassen
dominik lässt meister
türkische polizisten feuerten tränengas
in richtung griechenland auch heute
versuchen flüchtlinge nach europa zu
gelangen die die es schaffen werden von
den griechen festgesetzt und
zurückgeschickt zum teil
menschenunwürdig wie diese aufnahmen
einer türkischen nachrichtenagentur
zeigen spielball in dem grenzkonflikt
sind die flüchtlinge die weiter auf der
türkischen seite aus haren darauf warten
dass sich was tut an der grenze wir
haben alles zurückgelassen und gesagt
dass wir gehen werden und wir warten
hier bis die griechen die grenze öffnen
damit wir nach deutschland können wir
wollen dass es unseren kindern einmal
besser geht als uns entspannung könnte
es an der küste geben der türkische
präsident wies die küstenwache an
flüchtlinge nicht mehr mit booten die
igs überqueren zu lassen
in sachen eu türkei abkommen wird
griechenlands ministerpräsident deutlich
in einem cnn-interview
das abkommen ist tot das ist tot weil
die türkei entschieden hat es zu
verletzten wegen dem was in syrien
passiert ist die türkei hat die
verpflichtung menschen daran zu hindern
die küste zu erreichen
sie muss alles tun um gegen schlepper
vorzugehen und verhindern dass menschen
illegal nach griechenland gelangen
griechenland ist zunehmend überfordert
allein im flüchtlingslager mori auf
lesbos leben 19.000 menschen unter
katastrophalen bedingungen gegen die
zustände in griechischen
flüchtlingslagern und an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze haben
bundesweit tausende menschen
demonstriert wie hier in berlin
forderten sie deutschland solle
flüchtlinge aufnehmen und die eu müsse
ihre gemeinsame strategie ändern und die
grenzen für schutzbedürftige menschen
öffnen
eine 35 stunden woche in der pflege bei
vollem lohnausgleich das schlägt
grünen-chefin baerbock vor dringend
benötigte fachkräfte könnten nur
gewonnen werden wenn sich neben
angemessenen löhnen
auch die arbeitsbedingungen endeten
heute seien 40.000 stellen in der pflege
unbesetzt sagte baerbock der rheinischen
post
boeing hat seit den beiden abstürzen von
737 max maschinen gewaltige probleme
jetzt kommt die nächste schlechte
nachricht ein untersuchungsausschuss im
us-kongress hält die 737 max für
grundlegend fehlerhaft und unsicher
außerdem herrsche bei dem flugzeugbauer
eine kultur des verheimlichen
heftige kritik gibt es auch an der
aufsichtsbehörde fsa die überprüfung der
modellreihe sei in grober weise
unzureichend gewesen
nach den abstürzen mit 346 toten dürfen
flieger vom typ 737 max weltweit nicht
mehr starten
seit monaten schon demonstrieren
regierungskritiker in chile gegen
niedrige löhne und hohe
lebenshaltungskosten
nachdem die protestwelle
zwischenzeitlich nachgelassen hatte
gehen jetzt wieder mehr menschen auf die
straße in der hauptstadt santiago
versammelten sich gestern mehrere
tausend darunter auch vermummte
steinewerfer ein polizeifahrzeug in
flammen auf die sicherheitskräfte
setzten tränengas und wasserwerfer ein
tja und nun zu den arbeiten zur ersten
fußball bundesliga da blieb er dieses
wochenende mal alles ruhig vergleich zum
letzten allerdings bislang wirklich
keine nennenswerten anfeindungen gegen
den dfb und hoffenheims mit zehn dietmar
hopp dafür einen nennenswerten heimsieg
nämlich der leverkusener gegen die
eintracht hier die bisherigen ergebnisse
des 25 spieltags leverkusen schlägt
frankfurt souverän mit 14 0 wolfsburg
und leipzig trennen sich torlos 0 0 rb
lässt damit wichtige punkte im
titelrennen liegen unentschieden auch
zwischen hertha und bremen 2 zu 2 obwohl
werder schon nach nur sechs minuten mit
2 0 führte freiburg besiegte union
berlin mit 3 zu 1 punkteteilung im spiel
schalke und hoffenheim 1 1 und das
abendspiel borussia ging borussia also
gladbach gegen dortmund bereits gestern
unterlag paderborn dem fc köln mit 1 zu
2 morgen dann noch bayern gegen augsburg
und mainz gegen
die tabelle die bayern bleiben erster
dahinter leipzig dortmund leverkusen
gladbach und schalke mit köln beginnt
die zweite tabellenhälfte und am ende
nichts neues düsseldorf sechzehnter
bremen 17 und paderborn weiterhin das
schlusslicht und das top abendspiel
gladbach gegen dortmund ausführlich im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast
der sportchef von werder bremen frank
baumann deutschland da hat zum zweiten
mal nach 2009 10 die davis-cup-final
rolle in madrid erreicht dank eines
souveränen jan lennard struff die nummer
34 der welt und nummer eins der
deutschen mannschaft holte mit dem 6 2 3
6 2 gegen diego ribas ihm nur den
entscheidenden dritten punkt in der
qualifikation gegen weißrussland zum
wintersport bei den letzten biathlon
staffel rennen der weltcupsaison in nove
mesto haben die deutschen männer nur den
fünften platz erreicht die damen dagegen
schafften den sprung aufs podest sie
wurde dritte
nach einer energieleistung reicht die
kraft noch aus kurz abzuheben
zur hälfte des rennens das deutsche
quartett an position vier das podest in
reichweite doch die eigentlich so starke
schützen franziska preuß zeigt schwächen
beim stehendanschlag muss einmal in die
strafrunde deutschland fällt zurück auf
rang fünf schlussläuferin denise
herrmann für die mannschaft zurück aufs
podest dank einer grandiosen
schlussrunde auf der zielgeraden die
attacke gegen die ukrainerin anna
petrowna platz drei es war richtig
strümpfe geraten da war noch nicht so
viele gelaufen da hat sie ja schon fast
überschlagen aber ja ich will kann ja
auch meine endschnelligkeit vertraut es
gewinnt erneut der weltmeister aus
norwegen im sechsten rennen der sechste
sieg auf rang zwei das quartett aus
frankreich und beim skisprung weltcup in
oslo da ist deutschland in teamspringen
auf dem zweiten platz gelandet und
musste sich nur gastgeber norwegen
geschlagen geben
es ist ein gelungener auftritte im
holmenkol und gleichzeitig ein
ausrufezeichen im wettbewerb einer
wettkampfserie die noch bis zum
kommenden wochenende in norwegen
ausgetragen wird es der deutsche staat
springer constantin schmid der 20
jährige überzeugt nach seinem
qualifikations sieg gestern erneut mit
starken sprüngen und führt weiter die
gesamtwertung an
stephan leyhe pius paschke und karl
geiger sorgen für eine solide
mannschaftsleistung mit platz zwei
erobert deutschland gleichzeitig die
führung in der nationenwertung des
gesamtweltcups nicht zu schlagen
die gastgeber aus norwegen sie siegen
souverän wie schon im vorjahr platz drei
belegt zu wenigen von winters wird
morgen wieder bei uns ausführlichen live
im zdf ab 10.15 ja was traurig aus ohne
zuschauer
und was macht das wetter am wochenende
sonne und dann wieder regen so sieht es
fast überall aus die details hat gleich
ist in terni für sie
das war es von uns das heute journal mit
marietta slomka heute gegen 22 uhr 45
und wir sind dann morgen wieder zur
stelle punkt 19 uhr
schön dass sie dabei waren und noch
einen entspannten samstagabend für sie
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter noch ist es
relativ trocken aber von westen her
nähert sich ein neues tief mit einem
regenband was uns morgen ab den
nachmittagsstunden dann erreicht in der
nacht verdichtet sich die bewölkung
schon vor allem im westen und im norden
deutschlands nach osten hin ist es
trocken und stern klar genauso wie im
süden nur an den alpen da gibt es noch
etwas schnee der lässt allmählich in der
nacht nach und dort ist es am kältesten
mit minus fünf grad und auch nach osten
in richtung leiste zum beispiel minus 1
grad ganz im westen sind es plus sieben
grad
morgen am vormittag kommen noch weitere
wochen ins land und es ist noch meist
trocken aber der wind legt zu aus
südwestlichen richtungen
im osten ist es freundlicher und auch im
süden gibt es sonnige abschnitte zum
nachmittag beginnt es aber im westen
dann zu regnen
ganz im süden noch relativ trocken und
mit sonnenschein temperaturen dazu dass
sieben grad im vogtland und 13 grad am
oberrhein
die nächsten tage gehen ziemlich
wechselhaft weiter mit schauern am
montag bei werten von sechs bis zwölf
grad oder am dienstag gibt es an der
nordsee sturmböen bis 14 mittwoch sogar
bis 17 grad
ein schöner abend